honey then we gonna have a good time
[Music]
babe we got a sparkle in her eyes let
away I'm counting down and do a starter
and again we come to Flair
yeah we play hard money then we gonna
have a good time a dozen ends up the sky
we gonna chose to join I've been feeling
it all day I wanna let you go I wanna
lose time I'm ready to roll
for long time
[Music]
good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it is Thursday and I
am joined by Nick viola yeah welcome
welcome everyone as it Millennials its
Millennials it's also link toasters Gen
X Gen Z Gen Y we'll take them all thanks
for having me baby boomers was good
we're so happy you're here you just did
this natural yesterday well fun yes and
now we're just like back-to-back I think
this is maybe your fourth time on the
toes which I think you are our number
one guest like I don't think anyone's
been on four times truly I'm gonna take
a moment yeah no it's a big if you've
been with us since the beginning you
know how big of a deal this this is this
time I feel like I've accomplished a
handful of things in my life this might
be number one I just think this is
really it just it never ceases to amaze
me like how anything can happen you know
and it really has affected we talked
about this on the show yesterday how I
watch The Bachelor now and like people
who I think I don't like it's like I
don't know what I like you know no you
but I'm sure that I don't like Christina
but that's not I mean I do think we
talked about this yesterday I think I
think paradise you get a more accurate
representation of people's personalities
I would agree with that because your
personality or the way you came off in
paradise when you went was great and
that's when it really turned around yeah
I mean I don't even say that like
piously for me it's like well that was
my best seasons of course it's accurate
but it's it's it's not siloed into the
story of of the bachelor bachelorette
you have so many characters and then you
have it's all based on your getting to
know you as it relates to getting to
know the bachelor about shret and in
paradise it's kind of there's really no
specific playbook they're kind of people
are all interacting and it's a really
more normal situation where there's
Maltin women there's multiple guys and
that's more normal and it's not normal
for 30 people to live in a house to go
after one person and like when someone
says hey man that's cool go go go make
out with the girl it's just a bizarre
world and how do we know how people who
would act right it's like none of
watching at home know how we would act
so it's like not fair for us to judge
necessarily like when that's not it's an
abnormal situation and people edit
themselves have you talked about like
you know yeah go and be like yeah
totally cool I'm just gonna say nice
things cuz I don't want to look bad
yeah you're fake yeah and then they go
in a little bit more like confident
something like whatever and in paradise
and you start seeing people for who they
are for sure well this is yesterday's
episode of the snatcher I thought was
like so great and informative we touched
on a lot of stuff it's number three in
the podcast where right now so like if
you want to go check it out this is
actually yeah overall number three TV
and film sorry so pretty I didn't look
at overall cuz so great yeah I'm gonna
take the win I'm gonna walk out great
yeah so the snatcher is snatching up all
those all those ratings that intro song
I still can't get over it you know today
I actually was whenever Margo comes on
the toy she always do you like snitch on
the toast and so that's why we do snitch
on the snatch and today I was gonna do
Nick on the toast but it's weird to sing
alone it is and I can't I wouldn't be
able to help you out yeah I wouldn't ask
you it was weird
I would want to I was really impressed
you guys just like busting it out yeah
give me a warning like hey we do this
thing because like to ask me didn't even
think once we started doing it we were
like oh that's like weird there's
someone else here but you were our first
guest on the statutory video is all
pretty good singers know Margo and I are
terrible Claudia is a good singer but
like when we sing together
I think Margo and I can hide you know
our are out of tune sounded nice thank
you very much and thank you for being on
it we talked so much bachelor stuff so
there will inevitably be less bachelor
talk today but you know we'll dip in and
out like we always do it's it's a
bachelor a heavy time it is you know
like like bachelors like the NFL I just
want to say do you feel like an NFL
player and it's like this is peak season
no off season though really yeah I guess
the most off season we got is like from
now until January it does get a little
dry I mean it's honestly like I keep
trying to move away and it keeps
bringing you back yeah I mean it's fine
it's I have a lot of friends in it and
you know with the podcast that I have I
talk about it a little bit and then
obvious it's always fun to come on shows
like this and yeah it's an entertaining
show you know
but I'm trying to like slowly separate
thank you thank you doing a good job
because your podcast isn't super
bachelor centric at all it's not and it
will probably be less and less but more
news to come on things that we're doing
with the bio files
you said something so funny about your
podcast yesterday how it's called the
vile files and people never know how to
pronounce your last name
you have cemented that there I really
messed up I mean the name I guess was
clever with like hey we want you know
the x-files we love the name here thank
you leave it like how your engine really
say my name quiet right which is fine
and it's not like the best sounding name
in general and then so like what should
I call my podcasts like I don't know
let's just throw my name in there yeah
then no you get right which can
encourage people to say it wrong yes
because it's really buy also would be
vile and then it's yeah it gives me
anxiety I don't know why did that nope I
it would give me anxiety too but it just
won't you know like from the outside
like it's all going well don't you guys
have the toasters and like I meet people
they're like I'm a toaster and it's a
cool like yeah it's a cool community
it's harder with the vile files yeah
people said suggested filers you say it
really fast and it could kind of sound
like oh yeah it sounds like slang for a
pedophile oh yeah yeah just doesn't ring
off the tongue
totally okay well we'll get some more
figures about toasters out there but so
far so good I'm gonna ask you some more
questions about your podcast later but
so I feel like even after yesterday like
you were just made for podcasting thank
you like like physically in terms of
like talking and also you just have such
great perspectives on things and we were
saying you are so woke it's crazy
Thanks like even talking out Ahri's
girls you were like well not his girls
yeah yeah but I guess you have to be but
it's cool uh yeah I mean I think you
know you got a roll of times but I'm my
personality is I always try to become
more and more progressive and
understanding of other people's flights
whether I agree or disagree I think
everyone has different perspectives and
I think it's just better to sound more
enlightened 100% you're doing a great
job we all we just have to try our best
yeah that's all we can do all we can do
well we have a great show for you today
hopefully so without further ado here
are the fast five stories that you need
to know before you wake up and take a
bite out of your morning toast okay
first up a story that Claudia would love
but I would be remiss if I don't if I
did not share with you that Ralph
Lauren's friends collection is an ode to
Rachel Green's iconic style friends fans
and Claudia and Margo rejoice it's safe
to say that Ralph Lauren will be there
for you now that they've dropped an
entire collection in honor of Rachel
Green's iconic ensembles the designer
brand and Bloomingdale's have teamed up
with Warner Brothers to celebrate the
beloved shows that's not necessarily
true 25th anniversary and it's all
available to shop now I love when things
are announced and they're available I
hate all this like lead time or like
movies that are the cast is announced
but it's not coming out for a year and a
half yeah right like that just doesn't
work 2019 we don't wait for things
no eights or I could wait maybe a season
but we were just talking about a movie
that's coming out or a movie that's
being made and the casting was being
finalized and it's like it's not gonna
be out and like till 2021 maybe and
that's just I don't want to get excited
about stuff I agree I mean I don't know
if you're probably maybe maybe not a Top
Gun fan I don't know okay it's like done
they've done filming it but it comes out
for like the trailers out it's out for
like a year later it's like let me know
when it's out no I don't want to spend
all this time like thinking about it I'd
rather just not know ignorant is less
this show we were talking about was I'm
the new American crime story about
Monica Lewinsky they're like casting it
is beanie Feldstein playing Monica
Lewinsky it's not what we had said I
heard about that I believe she had oh my
god well like Justin you're just saying
I just watched book-smart last night and
I so get it she's a great actress she
was just great in the movie and I'm
excited for her and I'm excited for the
whole hill family I can't believe that
their siblings and their full siblings
we were saying they might be half
siblings because they have different
last names but it's full their 1%
sister yeah they look so much alike sure
and they're both very talented actors
they really are she was so funny it was
a really cute cute movie I really liked
it it was very well done yeah
very well done directed by Olivia Wilde
mm-hmm
movie about women made by women written
by passes the Bechdel test what's that
oh it's so we did a sore yesterday
Marion Webster has announced their new
words in the dictionary and one of them
is and they're not even words it's
either like abbreviations or like two
words put together that now means
something else the one of them is the
Bechdel test which is a test that like
you put you give to like any like movie
or whatever to see if it has like an
enough female representation so it's
like does the movie have more than two
female characters yes to the female
characters talk about anything other
than a man yes so this movie definitely
passes yeah this show passes to actually
two yet today passes but I think also in
any movie where there's more women than
men it would inevitably pass I think
hope I hope I know I learned about it in
college so like I'm a little rusty and
friends Rachel worked for Ralph Lauren
Oh Gigi got me you know what I remember
I feel like that was her dream job yeah
that could be wrong right okay that
feels like that makes sense why like
Ralph Lauren's doing that yeah oh that
makes a lot of sense I was just thinking
cuz she like had like 90s over girl
style no you're totally right because
that sounds really friend of you or
anyone I'm friends you know I know it's
not your favorite movie okay well I just
like started I just finish like my first
full episode this week because my
husband's been watching it ever because
actually we watched it a lot growing up
as kids and I guess I liked it then but
you know people change and so have I so
Claudia Margo we're watching it all the
time and it really bothers me
uhm but I recently like have been trying
to be open-minded and it's still not for
me but I'm starting to like understand
what's going on and I would say I guess
Rachel cuz she has like the best hair
and the best clothes yeah but and
Claudia Margo like cannot stand Monica
but she doesn't bother me so much yet
they can't stand her they can't stand
her
she like is the worst thing that she
ruins the show Wow
yeah but no she doesn't ruin the show
because without you it's like the
tension released right who's your
favorite friend my favorite friend
I probably Ross because I feel like I'm
probably most like Ross even though I
don't want to be yeah you know if I'm
being honest I see that you know he's my
least favorite friends at based on what
it's the little that I really am
he's Claudia's most favorite friend
though you really appreciate him over
time he's like he's an acquired taste
and then Astro where'd you like Kenna I
could see that I kind of dig it like
obviously it's like the two obvious ones
are Rachel and Joey like how do you not
like Joey like how are you doing right
but after a while it's like it's kind of
a one-trick pony okay cuz I was saying I
kind of did like Joey like he's the only
one who made me like chuckle a little
bit sure he's like cute and charming
yeah but after a while it's just like
alright we got your stick got it you
know okay you know what that reminds me
of the guy from Entourage the brother
Johnny Drama Johnny Drama
he's like funny but it gets old I feel
yes yeah Ross has layers okay I saw I
once saw him at not Ross but David
Schwimmer David Schwimmer at a John and
minions in LA just getting it to go
order at where John and Vinny's oh I
don't know if you go to LA I'm sure it's
great I don't know anything better than
great is it uh what kind of fish are we
yeah
it's justice and I've been to a lot I
got Italian Russia well we're gonna be
in LA soon so make sure you know I
totally well also people are saying that
Rachel worked at Bloomingdale's at one
point too so that's why this collab
makes a lot of sense
oh yeah that's really cute they're
really going all out for the 25th
reunion that did 25th anniversary I mean
I think it was obviously a massive show
and it's still like had it stand fans
and it's like a moneymaker yeah
I mean you attached friends or Seinfeld
or any of those like shows from like the
late 90s early 2000s and
it's nostalgic yeah I mean none of the
ones that I watched like really made it
anywhere but that's just my cross to
bear like everything I love gets
cancelled and I don't like it's really
[ __ ] sad so anything that does that
make you feel like question your taste
so no you know what it does it because
uh if like I can't help what I like you
know it just it makes me question like
my place in this world
you know what I mean I'm just like I
there's no one like there's not enough
people who like what I like like what am
I doing here what does everyone like I
can't get behind friends like if
everyone loves friends and I and I don't
I feel strong like I feel firm in that
belief like what am I doing here
III get it did you ever are you too
young to know or appreciate Arrested
Development love Arrested Development
see that's why I thought maybe I think
yes and that won a lot of awards it got
cancelled it had like it was a it was a
slower burn yeah that's true I
appreciate that
yeah it's it's I don't mean everything
yeah like friends it's great but it's
like it makes sense it's easy to digest
and people often like very easy to
digest stuff for Arrested Development
it's like you gotta you gotta kind of
have to watch it and you can watch it
over and over there's like these little
like subtle jokes and dry humor and kind
of Easter eggs in there that you watch
over and over and you're like that's you
watch an episode for the fourth time and
then you finally like pick up on a joke
that they just kind of put in there
which makes it great yeah and I think I
mean that's what I really liked about it
no see I love that try actually was just
about to restart it but then I was
spending too much time on my phone and
I'm like I'm gonna ruin it for myself
you know first four seasons are very
rough rewatchable tone the new what
seasons I don't think I even watch them
once I have a question for you though
because you were saying you love
Seinfeld and we were talking about how
Seinfeld is coming to Netflix soon do
you watch curb eye yes but not like I
watch signs okay so I was gonna ask
which do you like better
but Seinfeld okay there's a nostalgic
aspect to it and it's simple in like I
love curb but sometimes it's like it
goes almost it's like it's really it
really goes for it yeah
but if the curve is great but Seinfeld
there is something so like it's great
because it's still very you know it's
older right so like obviously you watch
it and it's like cars are driving
technology is all different but very
relatable because they really talked a
lot about just relatable situations and
whether it's dating or not and you like
it still applies yes so much of what
they like talk about is very applicable
to today because it's a lot about just
relationship based dating kind of stuff
and it's I might give it a shot never
got it I never got into it I don't know
why but I feel like it I love kerb I
love it so much you have so I might like
I'm not gonna write it off yeah you got
to give it a get it yeah like get into
you can't like watch two episodes and
then like judge it let alone I will I
will I will do that once it comes sniff
licks in like forever
but watch the watch the bet okay
oh wait no what I think okay next up in
some like reboot news but also just icon
season Yolanda Hadid and Kris Jenner
pose as dynasty foes mom injures Yolanda
Hadid and Kris Jenner made look like
enemies in the iconic 1980s primetime
soap opera dynasty sporting some serious
shoulder pads and even recreating the
show's famous lily pond cat fight cat
fight between Joan Collins and Linda
Evans or as we know it at between Liz
Gillies and Nicolette Sheraton for a
Harper's Bazaar photoshoot okay this
whoever's idea this is deserves a raise
like first of all putting these two
women in a photo shoot together like
genius and then having it be like
dynasty centric one is just like iconic
and beautiful but two it's like really
that's the culture right now you know
they're both raising like a dynastic
family and I just learned an interesting
factoid about you today that I'm gonna
make you talk about because I was
telling I love the reboot of dynasty yes
and you told me that you auditioned for
the show the new one yes and I'm
deceased
what was the part it was I
remember their characters name it was it
guess it was like a guest star okay what
was like this I it was the lead I was
interacting with the main girl this yeah
Talan and there was some sort of love
interest aspects to it it was like a
year was it for Liam Liam Ridley could
ring a bell cuz he's like very much like
a main character now oh I mean he might
be dead
spoiler alert we don't know we don't
know yeah it was funny and I so just
kind of prepped for the audition I
watched like three or four episodes what
do you think it was great I mean it
wasn't my favorite show like yours but I
wanted to get the part and I didn't it's
such a great show you guys everyone we
if it gets cancelled like I'm giving up
how many seasons are the energy they're
going into their third season right now
like there's no third there's no
murmurings but you never know
like I don't check the ratings um shows
yeah you know I mean sometimes those
shows like if they have a strong
I think core audience like they'll keep
doing it as long as the numbers stay
thank you for you everyone out there
watching for watch every please and
Margaux don't even
um you do a bit of acting now yep uh I
feel as though have you ever the
audition for hallmark movie not
necessary well I've auditioned for a
homework like movie my first acting gig
I ever booked was a Christmas movie
called the Christmas cruise yes I
remember I remember I didn't realize it
was a Christmas cruise but you know it
was a cruise it was on he was on like I
own yeah yeah and then I actually had a
I got offered a part in a movie I don't
know if it was ended up on a hallmark
but it was again something I think they
would have initially tried to sell the
hallmark and I ended up turning it down
I just didn't feel good about the
project but it was one of those movies
where it was like a you know it opens up
and I'm like the nice it's like a high
school and I'm like this nice guy and
then like high school at first when you
fast for like 10 hours right like I
don't know they would have
they could have gotten Lucas to play
even high school sure
all right what it is shave that's
confusing to me because I recently
watched a movie with Jerry O'Connell and
Rebecca Romijn on hallmark and but
recently I mean two nights ago
I love homework by the way like that's
where you combine me and they had met 20
years ago and then it was that now in
the future but they used them and I was
like confused
they look the exact same I think like
Jerry O'Connell was wearing a beach put
your hair down or whatever I'm gonna say
more than six 10 15 years like you need
a different actor I don't think I look
that much different than 15 years well I
feel like if you just shoot that would
make a big difference they were like
they did nothing different I think was
there anything code like it was so
confusing anyways I was supposed to like
turn into like a stalker killer guy and
like obsessed with a girl or something
maybe it was a lifetime that sounds like
it was yes something in that in that
genre they're fun that is fun I would
love to see you in a hallmark movie I
feel like you could you could thrive I
will say I have a show coming out called
the coop I was produced by Funny or Die
comes out in like November it's like a
comedy series like Toni hails in it from
Arrested Development yeah it should be
should be fun
that's cool so do you want to do more
acting yeah I mean I work on acting
every week I have a coach and I take
classes and you know I'm lucky enough
obviously do all these other things that
I like when I get if I get offered a
role that I don't feel comfortable with
it I'm fine with with passing like it's
a passion project it's fun to do I don't
have to rely on it to make money yeah so
it's nice to I want to build credibility
in that space because I don't have a ton
and you know something I'm just doing
over time and we'll see if you know it
would be nice my goal and it comes on my
acting careers one day have to do
something and have people go oh that's
really good and then see me as like
someone who can act as opposed to the
guy who was on The Bachelor who just
happens to be in a show got it okay
we'll look out for you by the way for
what it's worth the toasters think you
would have
in a great stalker villain ex-boyfriend
just so you know it feels like a weird
like I don't know if that's a real
compliment I know maybe like I don't
know of course I mean it just means
you're acting Millie yeah
but also I guess Mark Wahlberg played a
good one in in fear myself who are some
hot stalker guys Oh like um like the guy
from big little lies you know sure he'd
like the peri it's like a bad guy he's a
really bad guy but like you still like
him who still like him as an actor yeah
yeah okay okay we'll look out for you
thanks Joe straight I feel like that's
something that I can't think of a
bachelor person who's like really gone
into acting and like all the way it's
really tough I mean it's I hadn't acted
before and I've you know taking a bunch
of improv classes and acting classes
I've been working out for three years I
still have a long way to go I don't know
if I'll ever quite get there but you
really appreciate just how talented
these actors are yeah who are great
performers and it's it's truly it's it's
amazing you and you as you start acting
you watch TV and movies very differently
in a sense because you know real good
actors when you're watching you don't
see them acting you see people being
these characters and you're enjoying the
movie and when you start acting you you
know is that kind of you study it that's
like wow you you think you have this you
know out of body kind of like you you
tell you know they're acting even though
it's beautiful you know you're acting
you think how are they doing that all
their little ticks and idiosyncrasies
and the choices they make and it's
really quite fascinating and it's really
hard to do and they're very talented so
that's well have you seen one spend time
in Hollywood
yeah it was so good so just saw it last
week well even that when you think of
like Leo's performance like in a trailer
or like the fact that he was playing an
actor acting a scene in a movie and had
to like that's really hard to do it's
really yeah I
impressed by the whole film and I'm not
much of a film buff you know I it's I'm
a huge Quentin Tarantino movie guys I
guess I guess I am too now like missus
I've seen I've seen a few I haven't seen
all nine of them I mean I love
inglorious basterds I just like love
this idea of like taking real events and
like with the outcome that you wish
happened yes you should my favorite
movie of all time is true romance okay
who's in it it's a lot of people is it
Quentin Tarantino it's Quentin
Tarantino's first movie he wrote he
wrote the script he didn't direct it
okay like Christian Slater's in it Brad
Pitt's in there James Randolph kini
Christopher Walken Dennis Hopper some
some people you may or may not remember
but these are icon actors okay I'm gonna
watch it it's amazing it's the greatest
love story of all time
but it also has a very Clinton Tarantino
it's been to it check it out
Truman it's hard sometimes hard to find
but I like Google Play you get it for
like 9 bucks yes now we do it's like 2
bucks you can find something anywhere
like iTunes itunes google play is pretty
good really everything well I have an
Apple TV yeah did you have cable I do
but honestly I don't know why I have
YouTube TV now I feel like I pay $100 a
month for for nothing I think I'm just
giving it away I know and now with all
these streaming platforms that you're
not easily gonna want to subscribe you
even have all the apps yeah it's gonna
waste so much money it's yeah it really
is by the way you were on Dancing with
the Stars I remember and now the new
season is out how did you like that
experience I loved it it was awesome
okay like real Amy already in shape but
do you get really in shape I mean yeah I
was I'm in shape so I didn't get in
better shape right but I will say you
use it my hips were always on fire
because like I have tight hips and
you're like always like wiggling around
and like and that my hips were always
hurting yeah so that was was a hard to
do but it was a lot of fun and I wish I
could do it again just because oh you do
I I'm I'm a pretty decent dancer and
like you know for a white guy at a
wedding in Wisconsin yeah I kill it but
I see that
ballroom dancing is very different and
hard and very technical and I would get
very nervous like totally nervous I
never really loosened up until the end
and I think I would just have more fun
like I was so worried about doing well I
think I would want to do it and I'm
never going to be able to do it and I
probably won't do it but it would be fun
to do it just to like really just try to
have I should have had more fun I
understand that I feel like people who
go on like have really liked it really
affects them like it's fun but it's like
it's so much pressure and they get so
nervous like I was reading Erika Jaynes
book she was on your season and she like
really had a hard time with it when
she's like a natural performer yeah it's
it's hard and because it's so technical
again like it's different it's not like
go to the wedding floor and do the
electric slide or I'll shake your hips
it's you know you're figuring out your
posture and the steps and there's a lot
of like technical moves and it's and
then you go there and then you don't
even think about the TV it's not the TV
it's the audience which is like you know
there's five or six thousand people in
the audience you know and so it's I got
I would get very very nervous but it was
a ton of fun it's a good group and it's
a whole different experience are you
watching this see I have not seen it but
I'm sure I'll tune in I'll probably
maybe try to go to one of the live shows
this season Oh that'd be cool and then
can be on TV you can see that as still
of like paradise has member I saw that
like great you know no totally paradise
hopefuls totally by the way sorry about
the construction like we're gonna we're
gonna crack some skulls don't worry
about it be the real experience yeah no
everyone if we have to hear it so do you
yeah everyone to know how this happens
and it's this is a new sound I don't
know what they're doing sounds like
maybe sawing who knows um next story a
bit of good news for Alec Baldwin whose
wife hilarya is pregnant with baby
number five I feel like she's always
pregnant and now it makes sense his five
babies and they haven't even been
married that long like he's been now
yeah and he's has other kids already so
that's exciting
Oh
she is 35 yeah good for her they're
expecting their fifth child after she
suffered suffered a miscarriage
earlier this year wow that is so
exciting and they feel like he's on a
high right now after the roast
he's been mom he's been on a high since
30 rock yes but then he has all these
like personal dramas and he obviously
has anger issues and it's like always
like not enough to completely like
cancel him ever but it's like Ouisa bad
taste in people's mouths like when he's
punching people in the street better
than before because he was like a while
ago he was he was my first celebrity
sighting of my life really
first time I was in New York okay were
you oh it was 28 okay later in my life
but I was like on the streets of Soho
and weirdly enough it was like a side
street with her no one was there which
is weird in New York because every
street there's always people and it was
this me you know it follow it and I just
remember just kind of nodding and being
like that's so cool and just kept
walking by but did you say hi I didn't
know what's your policy like when you
see celebrities I guess now that you're
a celebrity like it's different
I mean I've it hasn't really changed my
perspective hasn't changed
and I just I I act as if has always been
kind of my policy
you know like unless I really wanted to
say something like just hey I'm a big
fan and this keep on going I just but
him I just usually don't really want to
bother people I feel that I did except
when I I'm I don't get starstruck easily
except with certain men interesting
enough okay I think it's because the
same reason more like women are you know
more often follow women on social media
it's just like they you you admire
people because you can like you like
them or you if you don't necessarily
relate but when I saw David Beckham a
coffee shop near my place I saw most
like I'm looking at like at like [ __ ] it
I you know I got out like and I was like
and I have a picture on it and he was
very gracious and I was like hey I hate
to bother you but
I would love a picture and the best part
about that is I did all the things that
I kind of joke about with with people
with me yeah they're like you know most
of it most people are very nice have a
picture I'm a big fan but some once in a
while I get people who can be awkward
and they will say things like well I
don't know who you are and I don't want
to show but my friend loved see a friend
loves you and so I'm like hey David like
to take a you know I'd really appreciate
it tonight Gary I would take her with
you is super nice and that's taking the
picture I'm just like my sisters are
gonna love this and I thought to myself
you know it's like and I was just like
I'm like I'm also loving this too by the
way and so and he was very nice and yeah
that's and I post a picture and he
commented on it oh that's cool do you
ever like say something to someone and
then find out that they're a fan like
they know who you are they watch the
show oh yeah like maybe with like rachel
bilson rachel who did who doesn't happen
with SIA was probably the coolest oh my
god that is so cool she's cool
how is that I was at a party was it
Kourtney Kardashian's birthday no it was
my friend rumors birthday Rumer Willis
no okay and CEO is there and there's a
bunch of people and you know see it has
her and an Emmy but she's been more and
more about like showing yeah and so I
certainly knew of C I knew she's a
really big deal but I you know hadn't
really followed her that closely to know
exactly and so I'm just like saying hi
to people and then she just like goes hi
Nick I'm SIA
I want to introduce myself and I was
like oh like and then we sat down and
shot the [ __ ] for like 45 minutes and
she's the sweetest and super show but a
huge fan and like we just like talked
for a good hour but it was just like
you're like an iconic pop star and she
was like drilling me with questions and
that's such like an interesting thing
like who watches the show and I saw
yesterday Kendall Jenner was watching
the finale of paradise
she was streaming it in Milan like yeah
you have some what okay
no but that's pretty cool and now you
know because like we said like you and
January walked so that Saren Wells and
Gigi and Tyler and Demi and Mike could
run and I think that's meat thank you
for your work doing my part
yeah no it's really like it's exciting
as you know just like a pop culture
person who's interested in pop culture
like it's a really cool time it do you
think it's because I mean I don't want
to confirm or deny anything as far as
walking but it you know it was more like
that was even like two years ago seen as
more of like I don't know if you were if
that's like cool and now it's like but
even now you read stories where it's
like I kind of joke I mean I will like
Rachel as a friend and so like we you
know and so like there was an article
about like something about Rachel and I
if we were dating
and it mentioned like reality start
dating real celebrity that's hilarious
and I messaged sure I go I just gotta
ask what's it like to be a real
celebrity it was like but like there's
always this kind of honored undertone
yeah whether you know actor or you know
you know say GG intended but GG in a way
was kind of a reality TV star totally
but like yeah she's obviously like legit
model right but like she she has roots
in reality TV that's not where she got a
start
yeah so it makes also Kardashians
totally know and the Kardashians are
like are the biggest start like I think
the biggest stars in America period like
and the most a listen from there they
are reality TV spice I think that it's
like it's I'm performing like I told you
like I only watch reality TV like to me
like those are my stars like I don't
I don't like what I care about like
movie stars you know not at all no I
like to watch him in the movies but I
don't want to follow them on social
media like I barely want to ask if I ran
into one like I don't necessarily want
to there's no one there to go oh no
there's like a few people like Jason
Momoa it's just like I love him yes he's
my number one I guess like as far as
actresses go like I like Jennifer
Lawrence but like if I saw her at a
coffee shop like I was just like [ __ ] my
pants and leaves like I wouldn't say
something yeah but you can still shoot
your pants that's true but but I don't
know it's like even she had Instagram I
don't know that I would follow her
that's different
because like they're not as active and
they don't care there's nothing
interesting yeah and it's just like yeah
yeah this is me at the red carpet it's
like great no we have paparazzi for that
exactly yeah it's just interesting
interesting it's a cool time okay next
story
Winnie Harlow claps back after she's
accused of complaining about flying
coach she clap back she clap back she's
defending herself after critics after an
Instagram photo shoot yeah in which she
describes her struggles with flying
coach Dru backlash the model explained
in a post on Wednesday that our
struggles so she was saying um that she
put a picture of her like sleeping in
economy and she was like we had to get
on a flight where there were no business
class seats available so that we could
land in time for a shoot and she was
just like really tired um so she's
explaining the post on Wednesday that
after not sleeping for four days
straight a flight scheduled was
cancelled because she had a huge shoot
at 6:00 a.m. the next day Harlow had to
take the first flight available out
which meant she was bumped from business
class back to coach she said I realized
this may not seem like a big deal to
some but when a plane is your bedroom
and a flight the only time to get sleep
during a hectic fashion month it's
tiresome she captioned a photo of
herself sleeping on a friend's lap while
aboard the plane and their coach seats
regardless I'm grateful God works in
mysterious ways and everything happens
for a reason it's not everyday glamour
you do what you have to do to be
successful in your life wait what does
God have to do
she just lost me like and also I
understand her feeling this way like I'm
Shh oh sure sure first time you've like
if you ever fly business class you
didn't do it for most of my life and
when you do it you break a seal and yes
it's hard to go back no totally I have
not did it I have not broken that seal
personally like I am put me in coach
because I just feel like I am like the
smallest size door possible for openers
Hackett and coach like who can you know
sure and I totally once you break it you
can't go back it's hard but like I
understand feeling that way but it takes
a certain level of like what's the word
just like John drew toe thank you being
tone deaf to post that on Instagram not
only in that because it's like if you
want to post it and like make fun of it
or make even fun of yourself the fact
that you've become a bit pampered and a
bit of it like I'll make fun of myself
for being like gah
have to fly coach like because it's a
these are like truly you know first
world problems of like you know one
miracle of flight you know and so you
know she it's written in such a poor me
and like looking for like empathy from
her followers yeah and then what what
has got like plan for all of us like
that what does this have this plan that
applies like if the prior flight went
down like that would be the plan yeah
that's like but if it did like didn't a
bunch of other people died and then you
got to live for that that was his plan I
mean what are the other family members
of the 300 souls that passed away
they're probably [ __ ] you like nice
plant it's such a [ __ ] thing I'm
gonna go on my soapbox or like it got it
had things happen for a reason
yes [ __ ] happens and we learn from it
and hopefully if we're open to it we can
improve and it will work out but like it
didn't happen for a reason
no I actually am a firm believer that
everything happens Ferguson um I just
think it's like first of all like that's
just how I think but also it
it's like an also an easy way to think
you know it's I believe things work out
yeah they work out because like we
experience life and then something
happens and we either like learn from it
or we don't and then if we don't learn
from it we do it again and we finally
were like okay I'm gonna stop doing this
if it happens for a reason like we make
choices and we learn from it like to
happen for a reason is a way I things
will happen and it's a coping mechanism
yeah it's for sure coping mechanism but
it helps you just make sense of like
this craziness that is life but I also
feel and I say I feel that way in
general but like wheat for example we
were on a flight on Saturday and we went
up in the air for 10 minutes and then we
had to turn around and go back and and
not at one point I mean then we were
delayed for like 6 7 hours it was a
horrible travel day and I really felt
like Whitney Harlow at not one point did
I say everything happens for a reason
like this is just sucks sucks and like
there's nothing that came out of it that
like you know I'm glad I was in Austin
for those those few hours actually we
did run into Olivia crazy and it was
really nice to reconnect but like I also
could have been home so I had someone
who have to think it's like it's a
butterfly a flag well yeah
life is weird and and all these things
happened and as long as we just are like
present and willing to experience what
goes on and I'm terrible at being
present and appreciating the moment but
yeah if we can and life's always better
because like you just never really know
what's gonna happen yes but I don't know
if it's like applies to being in an
airport for seven hours like I know
what's gonna happen and it's not gonna
[ __ ] sucks and I don't think anyone
has to die for me to be like everything
happens for a reason thank you
totally I agree with that yeah no this
is just like super super tone sorry
toasters it's a matter of everything
we're lovin make-a-wish yeah but she is
she should probably stop posting stuff
like that yeah yeah I totally agree and
I'm sure she will now because also she
could have posted such a cute picture
she's sleeping on her makeup artist
Mario who's also Kim's makeup artist and
she just could have had like a cute
caption yeah you know we didn't need to
hear like about how she really would
have said something like and what am i
cool that I have a caption for her it's
sometimes it gets the point of what she
wants to get a
Pras but awful playful and it could have
just said slumming it totally it's it
totally it'd have been great yeah I
think you should be a social media
consultant okay so I'm assuming that
noise isn't gonna go away we're working
on it okay I hope you guys have sorry
guys yeah we're sorry
we'll talk later eleven lemon make a
wish I hope this noise goes away and I
hope it's not as bad as it is for us
okay fifth and final story a little more
gross food news KFC is testing fried
chicken sandwich that's between two
glazed doughnuts this is sickening you
guys like and I'm all about junk food
fast food like delicious food but and
this is insane it makes it it makes me
worried for America it really does like
no one's asking for this like if someone
really is like they can go in my two
ladies donuts and put it in between a
chicken sandwich like it shouldn't be so
easy yes you get this and and like a
major food rush chain restaurant is
coming up with this so they have done
like apparently the studies and think
that enough of people will buy this
right right
anyway like it's too much I get salty
and sweet by the way if you like salty
and sweet and you like peanut butter and
you like pickles put it on toast you're
welcome it's delicious but also like too
much sugar and greasy fried food yeah
would I try a bite maybe but and I can
only like yes I'm sure like at first
it's like almost sounds tastes rich and
good but or like I'd rather have a piece
of fried chicken and a donut for dessert
I guess they're playing off the whole
like chicken and waffles except they're
just like trying to try something new
but like this is getting out of hand and
really like all of these fast food
chains are getting so that's thirsty you
know they're always talking to each
other on Twitter and like clapping back
and trying to go viral and now of this
like chicken sandwich wars I don't know
I don't I don't know anything what is
your thought on the chicken sandwich um
so I don't eat like I'm I don't need I
eat only kosher me so I don't eat meat
out at like places like this but that's
why I'm so excited about this whole like
impossible burgers revolution revolución
last night it is so exciting I have some
friends lesson at dinner tell me about
the impossible order and they stopped
eating meat a year ago and I'm a heavy
meat eater so much that I would like to
eat less meat but hey I love it and I
always kind of roll my eyes when when my
vegetarian or vegan friends are like oh
you've gotta taste this it tastes just
like me you won't know the difference
and I'm like I will know you really know
that I'm glad you like it and I'm glad
but like don't tell me it's the same my
friend
swears by it so the first time I had it
I was at the movies that I pick and they
had an impossible burger and they said
meatless burger so I got it I took a
bite now say I send it back I was like
this is real meatless that's what I hear
they were like and I didn't know what
the impossible brand was I didn't know
that it's made to taste like real mean I
thought it was just with me a veggie
burger and they were like no that's what
everyone says but really it's meatless
and I was in shock I couldn't believe it
now I understand that that's what it's
supposed to do and I'm sure as a
meat-eater you would tell the difference
but as someone who doesn't eat meat like
not only does it taste like meat but now
we have like options available for us
like a you see I go to McDonald's like I
can only get like fries in a soda and
like now I can get like a whopper hold
an impossible whopper exciting it is ten
billion dollar market cap I think it's
it's so or not only like for vegans and
vegetarians but like I think for people
who eat a lot of meat who are now like
worried that they're eating too much
meat like it's a good option now totally
it's it's not healthy to eat a ton of
red meat or meat in general and I know
this and I try not to I just love like
people have been eating meat forever and
they're doing okay so I think well they
are but okay as a relative term we we
are unhealthy country this stream comes
our diets but like I don't think they're
talking about you you know no but I
actually I've I've been blessed with a
high metabolism
and so like it's fun it's great I'm not
complaining it's actually fantastic and
that being said you know my sister's a
holistic nutritionist and so she's a
very conscientious and stuff like what
you put in your body and she's informed
me of a lot of stuff to me
that gives me pause do you watch those
documentaries I try not to and those are
sometimes a little nuts but I am worried
about what I'm putting my body because
you know I can say it look fine naked
but what happens I don't know what my
insides are looking like and I've become
more conscious of of that yeah I know
and I when you eat stuff is you don't
like you feel it in your bones like if I
know a lot of sugar or when you eat a
lot of meat you like you and when you
don't rather you also have more energy
you feel fresher and so there's
definitely things about that side become
very conscious of what I'm eating not so
much for outward appearances but for ya
health that's cool I feel like I've
become more conscious too mostly because
we work with all these like brands now
on this show that are really like
natural and organic and like we try them
out and we're like oh this is awesome
like thrive market like and we get like
healthy snacks and this show has
actually made us a lot more like
sustainable inside and out it really
yeah I've noticed that on my podcast
Davis or like brands like follow this
this is just actually I'm into this look
it's a really like they're doing great
things and obviously I've become more
aware of it with like natural habits and
using essential oils and my sister kind
of got me into all that just being aware
of what we're putting in our bodies our
skin is our largest organ and anything
we absorbed onto our skin we can absorb
into our blood and we should make sure
that's to give ourselves like a car you
know would you put corn oil in your
engine I guess I don't think I would run
very well I guess that's what we do well
before I get into questions for you
speaking of your essential oils you have
a code for the toasters and I love your
I'm not just like blowing smoke I love
your essential I am well I mean I feel
like I use it I feel like now I could
use it more than I do I use it when I
travel like on a plane just helps me
relax everyone's are very convenient
yeah I'll use it before I go to sleep
sometimes I just like to like smell it
so that it gets in my aromas yeah yeah I
don't know what to think
it is a thing well part of it too is
like when you breathe it like it's just
kind of a
centering mentality and like utility
just focus on your breath and you help
relax and then the cents help but
toasters I activated that code 35% off
which is the best code I have available
that's nice for the toasters oh my god
toasters 35% coasters coasters plural
you guys I truly I love it and now I
have your diffuser yes which is
wonderful quietly nice sold out though
we'll get some in stock about a week but
the pure essential oils on the roll-ons
are great for travel and you can get
them in the bundle I love them for
travel okay now I'm gonna take some
questions that we got for you because we
have some good ones um well you've been
doing the podcast for a while who has
been like your favorite guest so far my
favorite guest so far
I really liked Nikki Glaser she's a
friend and a comedian and it was just
kind of a fun banter I actually you know
date I've maybe maybe Hannah honestly in
the sense that I didn't really know her
very well and I don't like on my podcast
when I have a bachelor guest we I try
not to be very bachelor II it's like I'm
not so interested in like what happened
week three and why'd you send so-and-so
home like yeah I'll let the you know
other podcasts do like I want to get to
know the person and and in Hannah was
very kind of open and talked and showed
her personality and kind of talked a lot
about our insecurities and inner
strengths and things that she's
confident in I really quite enjoyed it
yeah and who's a dream guest for you
have so many uh Chrissy Teigen would cry
if I had to pick one I just as it
relates to my audience and I what I find
fascinating about her and she's very
outspoken I had a pleasure of meeting
her but I think she would be great and
then obviously you even Claud
oh we're guy we're coming uh what would
be great guess and maybe as a male dream
guest
[Music]
yeah I met my biggest man crushes Brad
Pitt same he's a dream yeah he seems
like the coolest guy he does who I would
like to be I wish I could be that cool
have you heard this rumor going around I
don't know like Margo told us about it
it's either very true or very false that
him and Kourtney Kardashian are like an
item come on yep what do you think about
it because I love it
Kourtney is it used to be with Scott
Scott I'm just thinking out loud here
but right after my think my season I
can't in season there was some rumor
about me potentially going on the
Kardashians to date Kourtney should put
this is not true this is some [ __ ]
there was no there was no smoking there
was no fire no I was like uh-huh wow
this is awesome news to me but hey I was
like great but just saying if that were
true knowing that in some bizarro world
I was even considered the same as fear
and that somehow that maybe indirectly
meets means I'm on Brad Pitt's level
thank you yes but also is that because
he goes to the the church he's a big fan
of that so yes we were talking about how
he goes to Sunday service and then Margo
was telling us and I don't know it's a
chicken and eggs if it's even a
situation and by the way apparently guys
can't hear the construction which I'm
like so jealous of you um I'm not sure
if he goes because he's dating Courtney
or he started going and and now he's
hooking up with Courtney and it's like
or maybe they're not hooking up at all
um but yeah I don't know but it is an
interesting she's a beautiful woman and
you know we all know how we feel about
Brad yeah I mean why not I'm for it I'm
so for it and it's another example of
reality stars dating movie stars I it's
interesting I think it all really comes
down to is relatability and I think
before you know reality TV became what
it was
the the reason why you always do is
because that's what you relate to I
remember when I was younger and I would
say you know I think to myself why is
say Brad Pitt only why does he only date
these these people these famous before
or some other celebrity why can't they
date a normal person yeah
and again not to compare but once you
are in kind of this environment and you
and people recognize you and people can
act differently you feel less safe right
you feel like who can I trust who can I
be myself around and who makes me feel
like just a normal person and usually
people who have shared mutual
experiences do that right and so I think
before reality TV came out unless you
were like a an athlete or a movie star
TV saw a radio personality or whatever
you just had some access or or you
operate in that world maybe you were
like a like a stylist or whatever you
just come from around you didn't act
different we weren't freaking out every
time you met so-and-so and I think you
know look at the Kardashians certainly
they're in the spotlight they know it's
like to have you know to value their
privacy and have people you know kind of
treat them differently
that's very relatable and so I can see
how how the two you feel feel safe but I
also feel like that's why like with
reality TV stars even like Tyler see
it's like he's really a normal guy but
now overnight he became like you know
everyone's obsessed with him but it's
like GG it's her closest opportunity to
date a normal person you know because
he's still normal he hasn't been a
somebody for that long but he's used to
now he has fans too and he would it's
not like all on her totally but I don't
even think like again they're it's all
normal
right like yeah but like I know not
normal but like regular people sure but
like all I'm saying is if I don't know
about Tyler and and Gigi and and like
let's assume they're hanging out as
we've seen let's assume they're going to
the Netherlands together for a
grandmother's funeral it's a soon that's
that's the sin that's happening is that
yes overnight he is now having people
trying to get to him and coming up to me
and I have a nice butt like it can get
nerve wracking and you can get anxious
about that and it could be hard and Gigi
is he can talk to her about that
yeah and that's relatable it would be
harder to do that I've gone on dates
with like a nurse right and it's like
it's fine with me you know it's I'm I'm
a normal guy you're a normal girl let's
get a date and then a never least
sometimes questions come up and when you
talk about experiences people will say
sometimes like what do you think you're
cool or something and I'm like I mean I
don't even I'm just talking about like
this experience and it's sometimes if
they can't relate that you can get
defensive or awkward about it and they
don't know what to say and those are two
people who can vent about a situation
and they can say yeah yeah I know what
you mean you know yeah whether it's that
situation or two people two doctors who
are dating you know names right doctor
it's hard for a dr. Tatum I'm just
saying like if you're a doctor and like
you you know you're a surgeon someone
dies in your table hard for someone to
relate to that another surgeon might be
able to do that and when anyone relates
to you it's you connect with someone and
I just think those are reasons why that
happens interesting yeah I think that's
probably more than anything why you see
people staying in that in that bubble
mm-hmm
well speaking of dating we have so many
questions about like your relationship
status we talked about it a little bit
yesterday are you seeing someone I mean
I have an act of dating life okay that's
inviting yeah it's a good time it's a
good time it's a good time to date why
not we've seen some do you ever watch
Mad Men yeah that's the best show I
watched a lot of Mad Men
yeah no I'm obsessed with very perso I
mean I know you're you and trying
they're just friends I had the pleasure
of meeting Don really he was very
gracious I feel like he's so not Don in
real life because he's so goofy he is
goofy a charming way yeah I know but
like Don is so serious like he knew us
from Milwaukee and so he's a baseball
fan in st. Louis and so as we were
talking and he was about the I was
introduced to him by someone who I won't
name
about like like I was is like I have
Nick and the person introduced this is
like he was the bachelor into my ever
living shame I was like please don't cuz
I just want to be like hi I'm Nick you
know I'm talking like a person and I was
this like self-conscious about being
introduced to don draper as someone who
was the bachelor and I just wanted to
hang out with him yeah but he was very
nice and we talked a little baseball and
yeah very cool interesting factoid okay
so we have some math trim hard ice
questions um we spoke about this on the
show yesterday but we could go back so
now we have three couples who have made
it out of paradise alive alive alive
Kristen Katie Hannah and Dylan Demi and
Christian do you think any of them will
get married we mentioned this yesterday
Mike if I had to bet I would bet no and
a lot of that has to do with it's hard
relationships are hard in general it's
harder on TV and these relationships
it's there young couples and and
sometimes that makes it even harder you
know you have people who are still
experiencing the world and what they
like and sometimes when you're I know
for me when I was younger
you think you want one thing and the
next day you want something else you
know you never know so I wish him the
best and I could be totally wrong and I
say this knowing nothing about their
relationships in real life yeah so why
do you think so Peters The Bachelor if
you don't know now I know why what do
you think they look for when choosing a
Bachelor and why do you not think it was
Mike I don't why do I not think as a fan
of the show I thought Mike was sweet and
nice and charming I didn't personally
find him to be a compelling character
because I I thought he kind of said a
lot of nice things over and over which
is great and it doesn't make him a bad
guy at all probably thinks I'm a great
guy nice things about them it's very
hard to be the bachelor or the
Bachelorette and you're carrying
conversations with multiple people and
it's about the conversations and it's
hard and stressful so there is that now
I have no idea whether it might could be
good for that or not but those are
elements they consider and it's it's
hard to carry the show
they're all there's a lot of variables
that go into it we're like we talked
about in the show like I'm not saying
Mike's not a great guy but we got to see
a very siloed version of Mike and maybe
there's things about his life that who
knows he also like might be dating Demi
Lovato maybe he maybe he didn't want to
do it I don't know that's true and so
there's so many things that go into it
you know so yeah I it's not a reflection
of the people who they are whether they
are the bachelor or they're not a
bachelor but he he might have you know
just for example talking to Joe the
gross gross store Joe yeah you know
we're talking him three or four weeks
ago and there was a little bit of talk
about him being the bachelor after his
kind of catapult on paradise yeah him
Kendall broke up but he went home night
one on Becca season partly because he
was so brutally awkward around the
cameras like they they they saved him by
not showing this is by Joe's own
admission he truly was like I mean I
freaked out when I've met Annie for the
first time but he was so incredibly
awkward they were like I they didn't
want to castle on Paradise cuz like if
you can't talk man yeah and so it was
like and he he kind of warmed up to it
but like to do that like and a few beats
versus like giving speeches giving
toasts being able to talk to like 30
different people how women react to you
I think sometimes they like see how
women react you in person so like they
may have someone mind and then they
might go on to paradise and they realize
well all the girls thinks he's really
nice yeah no one's really into him I
that's how I felt about Mike by the end
of paradise in the beginning I was like
he is my bachelor and by the end I was
like he was there for so long he had a
lot of opportunities and no one was
interested there's something weird and
that could be done that I don't know I
know no one would say it but that's how
I feel oh I I will say it like it till
this there's a like they know what
they're doing there's people who wanted
everyone wanted Blake over Colton
everyone wanted anyone else but a Hanabi
you know
and and Hanabi was certainly great and
in Colton was a good bachelor you know
and it was entertaining and there's it
you can't just be the fan favorite in a
pretty face I do think and we can agree
also on this that they absolutely need
to have a person of color as a bachelor
sooner than later I should continue to
go out of their way to make that a
higher probability because a lot of it
it has to do with love and liking
someone and you know Rachel Rachel was
the Bachelorette because she is great
right but had she gone home night wanna
let's say she just left on her own you
know like there wouldn't have been a
story there ya know so you have to like
they have to go far yeah and so and that
has to do with general genuine
connections
so I want them you know we hope that
they continue to cast more people and
more opportunities and create situations
where there are connections with people
so that they have more options and then
they do that I totally agree well that's
a great note to end on also we talk a
lot more in depth about this stuff and
who they should be casting and changes
that the the franchise could make on the
episode of the snatchler so head over
there now if you want some more content
with Nick Viall thank you so much for
joining me here where can everyone
follow you get your senses listen to
your podcast follow me at Nick viola on
Instagram NH oils calm is the website
for natural habits and natural habits on
Instagram with a lot of great
information about sense oils how to use
them alternative ways to use them health
just feel good healthy options and then
vile Nicholas 28 on Twitter which also
terrible that's really bad it's really
bad and I yeah whatever it's just
Twitter no one's there we will see you
on Monday I will be hosting with Ben and
tomorrow's episode will be podcast only
with Claudia and Margot from wherever
they are on the dirty jeans tour get
your tickets at girl with no job com
have a great weekend everyone mine
actually technically starts right now
shout out to it doesn't feel my cousin's
girlfriend marry again she's going to
one of your shows I think in San
Francisco she's a VIP a o shout-out to
Mary have a great weekend everyone thank
you Mick
you